joining me now is ari fleischer former
white house press secretary author of
suppression deception snobbery and bias
why the press gets so much wrong as well
as jason chaffetz former house oversight
committee chair and sean duffy former
wisconsin congressman all three
fox news contributors um
mr duffy i want to start with you
because obviously wisconsin would have
benefited greatly from this power plant
the evaluations were complex
and incredibly thorough look democrats
republicans looking at this whole plan
for this plant the federal government
comes in
just says now this this isn't working
your reaction to this
yeah this is outrageous so number one
this is not a rich area the superior
wisconsin was in my old district
in an area for 40 50 years northern
wisconsin was all blue northern
minnesota was all blue all democrat it's
now hardcore red because of crazy
policies like this that come from
democrats laura it gets cold in northern
wisconsin it gets to be 30 below we need
reliable cheap energy
to make sure we can heat our homes and
what's outrageous about what the epa is
doing is the fact that this this power
plant is going to help mothball coal
burning power plants for this natural
gas burning power plant which means
there will be less co2 in the atmosphere
and the liberals are fighting to to
again mothball it um uh this plan and
what this this is the problem in
government
you can you can like donald trump you
can like george bush you can elect jason
chaffetz but unless you get rid of the
federal unions the deep state at the epa
you can never change policy donald trump
couldn't get rid of the radicals in the
epa so if any republican is again
elected to president do what scott
walker did in wisconsin eradicate the
union fire all these you know 40-year
employees at the epa bring in fresh
blood and you won't have these problems
but as long as you keep these radicals
employed you can never change course
listen they'll they'll take out existing
nuclear uh plants uh the coal plants gas
plants they'll take out wells they want
to get rid of everything so we're all
reliant on the federal government we
can't afford food gas
oil and so will to the government to
actually subsidize these costs for us
which means we're not independent we're
not free we rely on them it's insane
ari uh this they had jumped through all
these hoops for this and i'm using this
just as an example of what they're
capable of this would have reduced
strain on the grid this would have
reduced carbon dioxide emissions the way
this plant is set up it's actually
brilliant i read about it because i was
just in minnesota for eight days so i
read the whole thing it's stunning and
then these activists come in and they
roll right through so ari if a
republican gets elected to sean's point
there has to be a full reform of this
civil service
this is craziness
yeah i don't object to that at all on
the civil service people thought donald
trump oh my god schedule f is the the
way you do this and people are having
vapors it's actually true it is
meaningful civil service reform if you
get out the partisans but a couple
points here laura let's start with joe
biden's tape that you just rolled one he
has a real hard time putting one
sentence next to another sentence i mean
demand is getting worse
two
he said that energy prices are going to
go down as a result of this energy
prices are going to go up
because we are driving fossil fuels
which are the cheaper fuels out of
business that's if the democrats get
their way through massive subsidies to
corporations that make green energy that
always drives the price up
and and then the final point is none of
this is going to work if you think the
federal government can spend money and
make us
green or fix our energy issues it is
totally the wrong approach for the
federal government to take but there's a
final point here
democrats have party unity and that's
why they're going to be able to pass
this because senator kristen cinema of
arizona is on board and that is a lesson
to republicans party unity is important
and the democrats figured out at least
here how to stop arguing and get
something done republicans could learn
that lesson too oh i'll say and jason um
despite everything we've laid out here
wonder boy pete butterjudge you know
they think he's a hopeful for 2024
he's still blaming everyone
but the administration check it out
we continue to see shock waves
disrupting every part of our economy uh
from the pandemic and from the other uh
geopolitical and economic things that
are taking place we're just keeping our
heads down and doing the work in my
department that means making it easier
to afford evs other things that help
protect americans from the effects of
these ups and downs in the oil markets
jason this is a purposeful sabotage
yeah he was keeping his head down taking
a nap i was on maternity leave that's
where he's been this isn't putin's fault
this was absolutely self-inflicted pain
to the american people the the democrats
have unified as ary said and said we're
going to get rid of fossil fuels every
bit of energy is going to increase even
if it's going to be a cleaner for the
environment like this plant in wisconsin
which was going to save uh i think
reduce the emissions by about a million
tons over over a significant period of
time uh they don't want nuclear they
don't want anything they i'm all of the
above energy guy i think that's the way
to do this but this administration
they're going to do exactly what they
said get rid of every bit of petroleum
everybody's going to pay the price we
can't afford it
panel great to see all of you thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else